Hey ! Salut ! Aujourd'hui on est à Vert-Saint-Denis. On est où exactement ?
-On est à "La ..."
Où ça ?
- A "La ..." à Vert-Saint-Denis.
Rien compris... J'ai rien compris !
[rires]
Le stress les envahit !
-Le mec qui n'a pas de répartie. J'ai pas de répartie !
Je suis en date de tournée, je suis à la salle de La Citrouille. En fait il y a La Citrouille, ici et c'est une très jolie salle.
J'ai avec moi Philippe Roche en première partie, et j'ai surtout deux nouveaux potes avec moi.
Qui s'appellent:
-Jessy.
Enchanté Jessy ! Et...
-Axel.
Et Axel !
En me répondant par "oui" ou par "non", est-ce que tu penses que je peux connaître ta date de naissance ?
-Peut-être.
Peut-être ! [rires]
Il n'y a pas d'embrouille !
Et...?
-Non.
Non ! Evidemment que non Jessy !
Donc est-ce que je peux connaître votre signe astrologique ?
Non plus ?
...
-Non plus...
Ok.
Des signes astrologiques il y en a 12.
Donc si je le trouvai sur l'un de vous deux, j'aurai une chance sur 12 d'avoir bon en fait.
Si je le trouve sur les deux en même temps, j'avais une chance sur 24 de le trouver, etc.
Et c'est ça que je vais essayer de faire.
Donc ok, c'est clair, je ne peux pas connaître votre date de naissance, je ne peux pas connaître votre signe astrologique,
mais je vais essayer de le trouver.
On va utiliser deux techniques différentes.
On va commencer avec toi, Jessy. Je vais prendre ton poignet, ça s'appelle du cumberlandisme.
Tu vas me répondre dans ta tête, que par oui ou par non. Mais uniquement dans ta tête, c'est-à-dire ne cherche pas à me donner d'indices sur ton visage, ou quoi...
Je ne vais même pas te regarder, je vais regarder du coté d'Axel.
Tu me réponds par oui ou par non dans ta tête.
Tu es né dans le début d'année...
tu es né dans le milieu d'année...
tu es né dans la fin de l'année...
Plutot un mois chaud...
Plutot un mois froid...
Tu es fier de ton signe astrologique...
Tu n'es pas forcément fier de ton signe astrologique...
Ah d'accord ! J'ai des réponses...!
T'as vu c'est fou, parce que tu te poses des questions sur toi même là, Jessy.
-Oui.
Ok. J'ai une petite idée, je vais l'écrire ici.
Comme ça je vais pouvoir révéler les deux en même temps.
Ca marche ?
Je vais te poser des questions aussi à toi Axel, après.
-Si il trouve il est trop chaud quoi !
-Ah oui !
J'écris ça...
Ca pour moi c'est Jessy.
Alors pour toi ça va être différent.
Je vais dire tous les signes astrologiques, pas forcément tous. Tous ceux que je veux et dans l'ordre que je veux.
Et quand tu entends le tien, dans tête tu dis "Stop". Mais dans ta tête. Tu ne cherche pas à le laisser transparaitre.
Par exemple tu peux être capricorne.
Tu peux être sagittaire.
Tu peux être taureau.
Tu peux être lion.
Tu peux être poisson.
Tu peux être scorpion.
Tu peux être lion.
Tu peux être poisson.
Scorpion.
[rires]
Je crois que je l'ai aussi.
Ok. Je vous le dis, le premier que j'ai écrit c'est le signe que j'ai deviné pour Jessy.
Et le deuxième que j'ai écrit, c'est celui d'Axel. Celui du bas.
Jessy, est-ce que tu peux me dire ton signe astrologique ?
-Poisson.
D'accord le poisson. Et Axel ?
-Lion.
Poisson ! Lion !
Poisson et lion les gars !
Poisson et lion !
Merci beaucoup messieurs.
Ca va ?
[rires]
AAAH mais qu'est ce qu'il se passe ?!!
Tiens, je te le laisse du coup.
Merci de m'avoir suivi. N'oubliez pas de vous abonner la chaine, si vous pouvez prendre le temps, c'est cool, ça m'aide beaucoup.
Rendez-vous le 28 mars pour les Hallucinations Collectives.
Et début avril je serai à Mulhouse, à l'entrepôt théâtre.
Venez, c'est cool. Comme ça on fait des vidéos, avant ou après le spectacle, ça j'aime bien.
Merci beaucoup.
Et quant à nous, rendez-vous demain à 17H pour le prochain Mental Vlog.
Ciao !